our goal is to simplify this expression
for the squared error between those
endpoints just to remind ourselves what
we're doing we have these endpoints and
we're taking the sum of the squared
error between each of those endpoints
and our actual line y equals MX plus B
and we get this expression over here
which we've been simplifying over the
last couple of videos we're going to try
to simplify the expression as much as
possible and then we're going to try to
optimize we're going to try to minimize
this expression or find the M and B
values that minimize it or that's I
guess you can call it the best fitting
line now to do that it looks like we
were just getting making the algebra
even here you're in here you but this
next step is going to simplify things a
good bit so just to show you that what
is what is if I want to take the mean of
all of the squared values of the Y's so
that would be this that would be y1
squared plus y2 squared Y 2 squared plus
all the way to all the way to Y N
squared so I've summed n values n
squared values and then I want to divide
it by n since there are n values here
and this is the mean the mean of the Y's
squared that's how we can denote it just
like that that is the mean of the Y
squared or if you multiply both sides of
this equation by n you get y1 squared
plus y2 squared plus all the way to all
the way to yn squared Y n squared is
equal to n is equal to n let me do this
in different colors is equal to so this
is this is equal to n this n times the
mean of the squared values of Y and
notice this is exactly this is exactly
what we have over here that is n times
the mean of the squared values of Y or
the mean of the Y Squared's it's exactly
what that is and we can do that with
each of these
terms what is what is X 1 X 1 y 1 plus X
2 y 2 plus all the way to all the way to
X n yn well if we take this whole sum
and we divide it by n terms this is
going to be the mean value for x times y
for each of those points you multiply x
times y and you find the mean of all of
those products that's exactly what this
is well once again you multiply both
sides of this equation by n and you get
you get x 1 y 1 plus x 2 y 2 plus all
the way all the way to x and y n is
equal to is equal to n times the mean of
x wise the mean of the XY so n times the
mean of the X YS and I think you see
where this is going this term right here
so this term right here is going to be
equal to n times the mean of the
products of X Y this term right here is
n times the mean of the Y values that's
what this term right here is and then
this term right here is n times the mean
of the X the mean of the X is squared
well maybe the the mean of the x squared
values I should say this term right here
is the mean of the x's times n right if
you divided this by n you'd get the mean
since we're not dividing it by n this is
the mean times n and then this is
obviously we don't have to simplify
anything so let's rewrite everything
using our new notation knowing that
these are the means of these you know of
Y squared of X Y and all of that so our
squared error of the line
our squared error to the line from the
sum of the squared error to the line
from the tip from the endpoints is going
to equal to this term right here is n
let me color code it a little bit this
term right here is n times the mean of
the Y squared values
this term right here this term right
here is I'll do it all in this green
color is equal to negative 2 M that's
just that right there times n times n
times the mean of the XY values the
arithmetic mean and then we have this
term over here I think you can
appreciate this as simplifying the
algebraic expression a good bit this
term right over here is going to be
minus 2 B minus 2 B minus 2 B n minus 2
B n times the mean of the Y values and
then we have and then we have plus we
have this term right here plus M Squared
M squared times n times n times the mean
of the x squared values mean of the x
squared values and then we have almost
there home stretch we have this over
here which is plus 2 M B times n times
the mean of the X values and then
finally we have plus plus NB squared
plus n VA squared so really the last two
three videos all we've done is we've
simplified the expression the sum the
simple for the sum of the squared
differences from that those end points
to this line y equals MX plus B right
over here so that is kind of we're
finished the hard core algebra stage the
next stage we actually want to optimize
we actually want to optimize this we
actually want to optimize or actually
maybe a better way to talk about we want
to minimize we want to minimize this
line this this this expression right
over here we want to find the M and the
B values that minimize it and to help
visualize it we're going to start
breaking into a little bit of
three-dimensional calculus here but
hopefully it won't be too daunting if
you've done any partial derivatives it
won't be difficult this is a surface if
you view the if you view that you have
the X and y data points everything here
is a constant except for the MS
and the bees we're assuming that we have
the exes and why so we can figure out
the mean of the squared values of why
the mean of the XY product the mean of
the Y is the mean of the X squares we
assume that we those are all actual
numbers so this expression right here is
going to be it's actually going to be a
surface in three dimensions so you can
imagine this right here that is the M
axis this right here is the B axis that
is the B axis let me continue the M axis
and let me continue the B axis and then
you could imagine the vertical axis the
vertical axis the vertical axis here to
be the squared error this is the squared
error of the line axis so for any
combination of m and B's if you're in
the mb plane you pick some combination
of m and b you put it in this you put it
into this expression for the squared
error of line it'll give you a point and
if you do that for all of if you do it
for all of the combinations of M's and
B's you're going to get a surface you're
going to get a surface and it's going to
be a three the surface is going to look
something like this I'm gonna try my
best to draw it it's going to look like
it's going to look like it's going to
look something like this you could
almost imagine it as somewhat of a kind
of a bowl or you can even think of it as
a three-dimensional parabola if you if
you want to think of it that way instead
of instead of a parabola that just goes
like this if you were to kind of rotate
it around and distort it a little bit
you would get this thing that looks kind
of like a a cup or a thimble or whatever
and so what we want to do is we want to
find the M and B values that minimize
that minimize notice this is a
three-dimensional surface so I don't
know if I'm doing justice to it so you
can imagine let me see if I can you know
you could imagine a three-dimensional
surface that looks something like this
this is the back part that you're not
seeing so that's the inside of our three
dimensional surface we want to find the
M and B values that minimize the value
on the surface so there's some m and B
value right over here that minimizes it
and to do that to do that and I'll
actually do the calculation in the neck
video but to do that we just need to
find we're going to find the partial
derivative of this with respect to M and
we're going to find the partial
derivative of this with respect to B and
set both of them equal to zero because
at this minimum point in 2-door this I
guess you could say in in three
dimensions this minimum point on the
surface is going to occur this this
minimum point on the surface is when the
slope with respect to M and the slope
with respect to B is zero so at that
point the partial derivative of our
squared error with respect to M is going
to be equal to zero and and the partial
derivative of our squared error with
respect to B is going to be equal to
zero so all we're going to do in the
next video is take the partial
derivative of this expression with
respect to M set that equal to zero and
the partial derivative of this with
respect to B set that equal to zero and
then we're ready to solve for the M and
the B and the or the the particular M
and B